[Music]
you've got inflation fears out there
that is one of just many worries
weighing on the averages but in times of
high volatility you got to start looking
around where can investors go for
opportunity let's bring in kevin o'leary
and kevin you are always on the lookout
for opportunities if we are dealing with
high inflation first of all do you think
it sticks around and if that's the case
where would you be looking
i'd like to look for businesses that are
growing their cash flows have strong
balance sheets and are servicing the
demand at the time and you know it's
true that we have inflation and there's
a lot of concern about a recession i
don't see any of that in the short term
i mean
i'm living in the real world here with
over 30 private companies in our
portfolio in almost every geography in
the us
right now things are booming sales are
on fire cash flows are better than
they've ever been and i know we should
be pessimistic but i can't get there
right now because i'm trying to hire
people and i can't find them try and
find a server in los angeles for an
operation
for minimum wage 15
i have to pay 25 in some cases just to
get them to come to work so there's a
lot of demand at all levels for
employment so i'm not that worried about
the classic recession energy prices well
that was self-inflicted we shouldn't
have cancelled pipelines that was bad
policy it can be fixed supply chains
will be fixed as well so right now if i
were to buy stocks which i am doing
because
i mean you know you can't time the
market becky today's a good example if
you were not in the market today you
don't know which of the 20 or 30 days in
the next 12 months give you all the
returns today was one of them so trying
to time the market in volatility is next
to impossible but let's take something
like
service corp now maybe people don't know
it but it's probably the biggest funeral
operator in america guess what in
recessions people keep dying who knew
and their business is recession proof
and they have strong cash flows a good
balance sheet bg bungee you talked about
food concerns 80 supply chains all kinds
of specialized grains and oils all
across america fantastic nestle in
switzerland european company in swiss
francs you know this new act biden just
signed it's all nestled all that stuff
is coming from there nestle's supplying
all the baby formula and the baby
formula 2002 act or whatever he's
calling it why not own that company when
we're out of baby formula these are big
opportunities becky all through the
market that are going to perform very
well regardless of inflation
you know kevin i love the message the
real world ideas and just what you're
seeing as a as somebody who's running
businesses yourself i think those are
all incredibly valid points i also think
just this idea that you can't time
markets that really matters
of the company stocks that you're
picking does any of it have to do with
stocks that have come down pretty
significantly i know you talked about
facebook and or i guess i should say
meta and google being two companies do
you look at these things and say hey
this is a bargain versus where we were a
year ago
yes i do i say to myself okay what's
happened here is in many cases growth
rates have not slowed they're forecasted
to slow but it hasn't happened yet i
think in q4 we're actually going to beat
the estimates that analysts have taken
down maybe they're forecasting five
percent my bet is it's more like seven
eight nine percent growth for this
calendar year and then all of a sudden
you turn the switch into 2023 and say
the recession hits hard i don't think so
this is going to be an inoculated
recession it's already had a vaccine in
so many ways there's so much of the four
and a half trillion that was poured into
this market still in the pockets of
consumers and they haven't had a chance
to spend it yet because we have a
disruptive supply chain i've been
through many of these cycles this one is
unique and i'm not going to get too
bearish because if i went back to 2020
and looked at what happened in that year
that volatility the thousand-point days
up and down in a matter of 23 days the
entire returns were found so if you're
not in the market for those 23 days and
who knows how many will be in this cycle
you're not going to get any returns so
i'd argue to people look take an
advantage of this correction a johnson
and johnson a pfizer
google or meta and meta in case of the
old facebook these are companies that
are still cash flowing massive balance
sheets technology is not going away look
at zoom today everybody thought you know
that's correct they're over 78
and yet they beat their numbers people
are still using these technologies
they're just paying less for them on a
pe basis and that's a gift the market's
giving you right now if you like that
video waiting you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here and
subscribe